SIT BACKEP.
KOLE LIND WAS NOT.
AND SEATTLE IS OFF AND RUNNING!.
A NICE FOREHAND TO BACKHAND MOVE
FROM L SECOND.
BRINGS IT RIGHT IN.
HE HAS NOT MUCH OPENING UP OVER
THAT
PLAYS IT WELL OUT TO DEAD
CENTER.
HERE COMES ANSITION.
ABLE TO GO FIND THAT REBOUND AS
WELL.
LIND GOING IN.
THAT'S ANOTHER GOOD FALORADO IS.
KUHLMAN HAS OPEN
GOURDE, GOOD BOX-OUT
PICKED UP BY
DECIDING GAME OF THE FINAL FOUR.
WHAT A PLAY, WHAT A PASS EDGE.
A TOUGH ONE TO HANDLE.
NOT A LOT OF ROOMDED BY LEHKONE.
NOW,FTY LITTLE  BY FRANCOUZ.
McCAROM TEAMS IN THE
LEAGUE RIGHT NOW, FLORIDA AND
COLORADO..CK.
EBERLE WITH A SHOT, SHIELDED BY
NOW BURAKOVSKY STRETCHES
TAKES IT BACK, ESTABLISHES A
BREAKOUT.
FIRST OPPORTUNITY, THE REBOUND
OUTOVES IN.
A SAVE.
GIRARD GETS A PINBALLL OF TH IT.
HERE THEY COME.
THIS IS
COMPHER.
STURM.
NEWHOOK.
FANNED ON BY BYRAM.
OUT O JOHNSON.
OVER, JUST OPENS UP THE S
FIVE-HOLE A LITTLE BIT.E AT
CLIMATE PLEDGE ARENA. A GOOD OP.
KADRI DOWN DEEP.
21 AND A
FOR A MOMENT.
THEY GET IT BACK.
PIPI